now of course you guys know after the
whole body SPECT situation that I am a
perfect athlete in order to feed the
body of a perfect athlete you need a
perfect meal and what more is a perfect
meal than delicious Korean barbecue
[Music]
I know
today we are at [ __ ] Korean barbecue
over here on the west side mother [ __ ]
we're about to have a great food
experience now if you guys don't know my
homey Chris is over here about to cook
us some delectable delights this just
ain't your regular Korean barbecue and
you've never been here right no I never
been about this this is going to be
Korean barbecue that's elevated up to
the nut sac [ __ ] whoa this is
one of the joints that I personally love
out here in LA and if you haven't had an
amazing Korean barbecue experience
because you haven't been to hanji this
is my joint this is the spot this is the
place where people come to have babies
set all the time the bathrooms are clean
I can't wait to not have sex with you
this is really you're [ __ ] up Oh
[Music]
[ __ ] we are over here about the grub
on this delicious delicious delicious
food we all know what's before you if
you guys had Korean food before there we
are known for our [ __ ] side dishes
that's what we're about
it's the accoutrements to the vibhut
saman that's not even a [ __ ] word
it's accoutrement accoutrements is a
[ __ ] word no he's not thanks anymore
this is also known as punch on right am
I wrong about the cream buy a lot of
Korean barbecue is that you guys
probably go to in LA or in Koreatown
but hanji does something to Korean
barbecue that you don't see in those
type of places they're kind of elevated
with a lot of different flavors
this is um executive chef Chris oh of a
Han Jeep and also from a place that we
all know that I love
Seoul sausage why don't you let them
know a little bit about yourself and
what we're about to
I'm on today what's up fellows like they
said i'm chris oh chef owner of Pangaea
Seoul sausage
Escala my food trucks got like one
things going on but today we're gonna
feed you the the wonderful art of Korean
BBQ with a couple extra surprises so
he's the eyes open the mouth and just
let the food sex begin last time I did
that it wasn't good just to give you
guys a little bit more about Chris's
culinary background he was on the great
food truck race he won that he was on
cutthroat kitchen
he won that he was also on another
program on Esquire where he won that
food challenge as well so currently from
what I know he's undefeated Korean
people love fermentation like that's our
thing that's how we survive when we
didn't have like refrigeration so you'll
notice all our ships like fermented and
pickle like bean paste kimchi and sour
chicken a lot I'm gonna try some of this
stuff
oh we're gonna want to try some of the
punch on if you don't like kimchi then
you're obviously not Korean and you're
going to help staple Koreans my jam you
know what I do this might be super
Korean for you guys but um I like to get
white rice and then I get on butter then
I get the salted seaweed and then can
cheat BAM so bombs that is how great a
North Korean than I am Ajith and then
you get a tub salt and then you start
making your picture on the crew Dada
around with a neon pink glow I know but
when Mexican music in the back now we
could have came to this restaurant and
showed you guys the typical stuff that
you see in Korean barbecues but what's
the whole point of that I'm trying to
highlight why Hansie Korean barbecue is
so different so we got very unique
dishes that's unique to this place alone
[Music]
when you go eat at a lot of these Korean
joints specifically Korean bars they
have something called corn cheese now
corn cheese typically you'll see it'll
be like a stringy melty cheese with a
butter and mayonnaise which you know
when you hear it doesn't sound that
great but it's absolutely delicious but
Chris takes that and he elevates at once
again he adds bone marrow to that on top
of pudding and butter on there and on
top of that instead of the stringy
cheese
he adds like this delicious salty
parmesan that's great and right over it
who wants to put the butter down first
I'll do it no matter okay there you go
oh that's hot there you go next the corn
the corn and there you go here loss of
thermal sir normally we wouldn't be
cooking it but he kind of allowed us to
cook it just to show us that number one
how it's made and number two that it's
relatively easy to make - all right this
is ready to go out eat this already okay
no notice few more steps you guys will
know what bone marrow is yes I pure fat
oh we made it
I'm wicked it's it and then last but not
least oh they call it corn cheese you do
the cheese out of that holy crap
we're cookie and enjoy holy [ __ ]
so if you guys want to know what to
expect when you eat this you kind of get
like the sweetness from the corn you get
the fat from obviously the bone marrow
the Mayo and the butter and then you get
that nice saltiness from the cheese and
that's exactly what you have for a
perfect little bite and a photo class
really pretty bomb to happen yeah food
copy on anything is [ __ ] to do
good copy on rice alone is delicious you
put that on this [ __ ] game over do
bing-bang-boom sex I think that's how
sex works
we got served something called cat on
team but this cat on team basically is a
Korean steamed egg dish is the
rolls-royce of cat on jeans because it's
topped with eco de and also Unni and it
just kind of makes the flavor profile of
this dish just go straight through the
roof it's your classic Korean steamed
egg which is one of my face talking
badass make that money [ __ ] the way to
eat it is get a little bit of Unni oh
snap there get a little bit of it girl
it's like a Mount Vesuvius of just eight
goodness mm-hmm mmm that's good
good god yeah what is it why is it too
thick there's meat in here dude it's so
freakin good
this um come no you do you about shirako
the constant okay I was like what a
horror
uh-huh what a weird huh ank's Oh eggs
yes the female version of come there you
go sure
no yes sure she's trying I'm trying to
say faith caught me out on this before
that in your mouth I don't know what the
great thing about ikura it's like it's
like it's a great way of using a
different form of salt you know you saw
the it grows got a very like natural
brine from the sea and it gives a kind
of like a different level of salt so
Poseidon's Texas fan and it's not come
it's not because it's not not at all we
had we had a seaman in Japan when we had
like
Chico oh yeah the little thing yeah it
was like I I ate it what it was and just
like oh [ __ ] uncle I know this flavor
what is it I haven't had this before
reminds me of my child
Oh too dark too now anyways living out
loud pops in your mouth oh I know what's
cool about this kid I'm Jim is we'll
just call it Korean there's actually a
lot more egg in it than most other place
no real egg yes what is the other place
do they do they use I don't wanna say it
you can tell me no one watches this
channel use powdered eggs oh that's why
I don't have the egg flavor you're
naughty Koreans you you like the Jews of
the Asian world some piece of Jewish and
of course we had their Korean fried rice
as well done with some delicious
fermented kimchi a brown butter and it
was topped with a sous vide egg Suvi is
basically a method of cooking your food
at a very controlled temperature so
whatever you sous-vide you're going to
basically cook your food in a water bath
it does it very gently and it's a way to
basically not [ __ ] up cooking your food
and you'll see it typically done with a
lot of steaks but when you should be an
egg what happens is after you crack the
egg and is it's already done cooking
it'll lightly set the whites and it kind
of makes the the egg yolk into custody
like texture so that element added to
the already decadent brown butter kimchi
fried rice was absolutely amazing you do
is just slather it and then I'm excited
oh and then I put it on my plate thank
you
oh snap
enjoy I'm going to enjoy this melody oh
damn oh my god
this is the best kimchi photos again
yeah I'm not saying that cuz you're
sitting here I'm an [ __ ]
oh really good cuz if it was [ __ ] I
would tell you I won't even say anything
I'd be like I'm kind of cool so another
dish that was also brought out to us was
the Korean pork bridge which is kind of
like reverse Korean barbecue because
it's an American style cut but it still
has the bold Korean flavors attached to
it so it definitely has that play on a
salty and sweet and it's a very unique
unique Korean American food experience
all right so what you do is you pick it
up did you say you did like corn oh all
right
it's like a rhythm now yeah yeah no no
he's already judged you bro I think you
did a pretty good job of when we have
their worst first impression you can
move the salad that's okay you have your
own style
yep yep sweet spicy and salty
this is Bobby yeah we boil them we
braise them then we dry them out with
deep fry them you slather them in our
sauce and we throw them in the oven so
we give the ribs a little bit of love
another [ __ ] just falling right off the
[ __ ] bone look at this
I'm very happy you want everything to be
all over your face
yeah are you kidding me that's so bad
I've never click what the hell why did
you bring me here to broke up because I
don't like you how many [ __ ] about you
chris is a [ __ ] maniac like haha and
what I mean by maniac I mean it in like
the best way possible because he brought
this [ __ ] tomahawk steak which is
this huge piece of bone and [ __ ]
ribeye meat I just couldn't stop staring
yet it was beautiful it's like I saw
Jesus
oh it's like a meat lollipop exact are
you okay with the changer underwear it's
speaking to us so we do is we basically
seared here at the table and it all just
it's a big something s mosquito stuff if
you take forever to do here who did we
see on both sides take it back at the
kitchen you slice it up we put some foie
gras my mouth is watering meat and fire
there's something about looking at meat
and fire that brings out your hunger
just that
well then I'm sorry I love having a
moment here
I [ __ ] love rabbis to one of my
favorite cuts of all all time it is the
best cut what makes it a good cut the
fat to [ __ ] ratio look at the [ __ ] a
marble yeah [ __ ] do okay you
want to flip it sure can I flip it now
wait wait you gotta listen you're not
listening is it saying to flip me he's
saying [ __ ] me oh I would do it but then
my penis might say ha ha ha let's check
it this let's check to see if it he's
gay
oh I think she's ready I think she's
ready
I'm not putting put the phone on this
side huh there you go look at the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you I am look at this [ __ ] and look
in my RDF type of crust right here this
is where the flavor is
yes yes and please David explain to us
why we see her meat because it adds a
depth of [ __ ] flavor [ __ ] and
on top of that I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about
take it away Chris well that was
completely wrong
the reason why we see her me it's a lock
in the juices so Chris decides to go
ahead and ask me about my culinary
expertise to why why we sear the meat
which by the way he told me I was wrong
and I don't think I am yes when you
steer the meat it's just to kind of seal
the juices but you want to also Brown
and sear your meat because of that my
yard reaction which I'm always going to
talk about is where that sugar on top of
whatever protein that you're cooking
caramelize it and it adds a deep flavor
to your meat so [ __ ] you Chris now the
steak is done searing I'm going to take
it to the back give it a little spa
treatments oh nice and we'll be right
back
ah the piece they're ready on I don't
even know what that means what are we
have here but this is a shirt this is
our three pound little baby fresh out of
respawn Wheatsville oh yeah she's she's
been pampered I thought it'd be song
she's got the mani-pedi she's got the
massage she got hold of that you keep
having that me though those religious
and it's medium rare
oh my god can i slide into this right
now that go for stir crazy
Wow oh [ __ ] I've been into that [ __ ]
and I went to heaven
that's it doesn't there's nothing else
to say I've been into it and I said
Homer Simpson you should have this side
holy [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ] good yeah this
is ashes argh asthma for sure this is
how beef [ __ ] tastes holy Wow
we have like these dipping sauces on the
side I don't want to taint it it is no
here no more I don't want to taint it
it's not made for this fat right here
yes and all that butter all i meanwhat
thought about butter is that again once
again it's a foie gras butter if you
guys know what foie gras is it's duck
liver fatty duck liver it's so fatty is
so tender to describe it you just use
disparity or wonderful years with the
texture and the flavor it's very tender
there's a lot of fat cons into it you
guys already know fat equals [ __ ]
flavor right so not only do you have the
fatty [ __ ] ribeye
you have the fat from the flock and the
[ __ ] butter on top of that and the
butter season mm-hmm perfect perfect oh
you should some scissors Gio when she
ate that piece of meat she was just out
of this world you know that girl doesn't
even really like food that much so the
fact that she reacted to that piece of
meat that way amazing sounds a little
sexually suggestive I don't care no mind
you are like growing up I never really
ate me didn't really like it and what I
found out was the reason why I didn't
like beef was because it was a cook
properly my mom used to always nuke the
beef mmm to death so she would do like
you know American people steak and you
know she would do like you know that
Montreal seasoning that everybody gets
oh yeah and they she was wrinkled that
and then she would nuke that [ __ ] and it
would just be dry but my just she's a
great chef when it comes to Korean food
but I feel like when it comes to beef
during whatever she wrote but at that
time beef wasn't a huge commodity in
Korea it was very expensive and so in
terms of cooking and eating a lot it was
used as a small part of your dish versus
the main so you know techniques
it wasn't huge in Korea so she would
always just cook it however she would
I'd want to keep like Top Chef when you
have like small pieces of beef and you
cook it all the way through so when I
had like that my very first like
medium-rare steak changed my life then
no it could taste like that you think
even just at home
no do you think you could do so home I
can't even put the full that's the whole
same yo Korean people aren't really
known for the desserts it's not
something that it's like our forte but
he definitely did a great job on
something very simple watermelon this is
our world-famous watermelon soju
what is Paul George made is very famous
and it was featured on The Wall Street
Journal
what yep damn congratulate not my
busiest not my business savvy but my
watermelon soju mix Wall Street so my
mom is very very not proud but what now
she's my mom's ok so this is what you do
so the trick is we go soju first ok ok
right oh I thought all that slow watch
slowed down and then we go fruity
pebbles
I sprinkle the whole thing just go crazy
go world oh my god and pop rock pop
rocks
let it's free
oh and last but not least you got to
hear the rock pop yes what do you what
is this this is crazy this is amazing so
we want to do after that is just take
your spoon grab a ball eat it like an
apple drink the soju I mean it is it is
definitely um it's good so no yeah like
see you like you know like oh oh oh yeah
yeah
what there's one more thing oh oh if you
guys don't know by the way Jill has a
crazy sweet tooth and he decided to
bring out this delicious choco pie not
your typical children pie that you're
giving the package it was an ice cream
version of that blew my mind I grew up
on choco pies as a kid there's also
something called a moon pie yeah
decadent I guess more he's very thick
which I'm not a big oh my god there you
go I don't want to take spoon in my
mouth like David
yeah it's like a moon pie and then like
cold stone just [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
each other
dude if you're like vegetarian and
you're not trying to give you just calm
down just for this stuff and the pond
Tron's bomb the the homemade truck apply
ice cream oh wow oh my god
and uh honey boss has read a lot of like
vegan friendly dishes yeah right I think
is gonna give you a Korean barbecue
experience that you're not gonna have
anywhere else
I guarantee you there's nothing wrong
with traditional Korean barbecue I
absolutely love that but if you're
looking for something different and to
kind of challenge your tastebuds to see
where you could take Korean food come to
Hangzhou Korean barbecue it's one of my
favorite spots and you will not be
disappointed so go out on a weekend or
maybe even a weekday treat yourself to
something delicious
well everybody that was one of the best
[ __ ] meals I've ever had in my life
Korean barbecue upscale to a mother
[ __ ]
Kris why don't you let us know how to
get here well we want to get that
deliciousness Google
I'm Jim every time you access [ __ ] for
real Hansa barbecue Instagram Facebook
all that good stuff come by we're
downtown Culver City they loved it they
loved it you guys will definitely think
it's like okay at least no no you guys
are gonna cream your pants for sure
[Music]